merci à joffroid Didier pour son
introduction très louangeuse je sais pas
si elle est vraie mais en tout cas je
sais qu'elle est amicale et elle me
permet ce soir de vous dire d'abord mon
bonheur de vous retrouver ma joie de
vous voir nombreux de voir la qualité
des débats des échanges des tablesrondes
la qualité des intervenants qui euh
marquent notre
volonté de retrouver un débat d'idée
dans des moments qui politiquement ne
sont pas simples mais avec cette volonté
très claire de retrouver la seule place
qui doit nous convenir c'est-à-dire la
première pour redresser notre pays pour
s'attaquer au défis du futur de l'avenir
et de le faire d'abord sur le terrain
des idées donc merci à tous les
participants merci
autour de geoffroid Didier qui porte ses
états généraux qui se veulent le creuser
d'un bouillonnement d'idé
d'un embrasement de de nos valeurs que
nous voulons voir très clairement défini
arrêté et orienté vers l'avenir en début
d'année 2024 d'avoir organisé ce soir
ici dans ce lieu un peu inédit pour nous
et bien ces échanges je veux également
exprimer ma reconnaissance à Antoine
Vermorel qui porte avec le dynamisme de
la jeunesse briillant nouveau député élu
en 2022 il y a pas de beaucoup de de
députés qui ont gagné dans notre famille
politique des circonscriptions 2022 il
en fait partie et il porte cette
expérience forte sur les questions
environnementales alors ce soir nous
abordons tout à la fois cet enjeu
environnemental
avec humilité et avec détermination
l'humilité qu'inspire un sujet aussi
grave d'éminents spécialistes ont posé
le
diagnostic je crois que nous y adhérons
tous en tout cas je veux le dire j'y
adhère avec force on ne conteste pas une
réalité elle s'impose à nous et ce défi
climatique le défi du changement
climatique il est malheureusement
présent
et il porte en lui une part de l'avenir
tout simplement de
l'humanité tout
entière nous voulons et nous devons en
parler et nous devons en parler en
mesurant les
enjeux ce défi climatique oui c'est un
défi vital c'est un défi majeur c'est un
défi
essentiel nous le savons et nous le
disons et nous voulons et nous avons le
devoir de le dire avec
force dans ce contexte nous devons aussi
exprimer notre
vérité nous ne devons pas nous laisser
caricaturer trop souvent notre famille
politique a été enfermé dans une case
par les donneurs de leçons
habituelles nous disons que notre
histoire et cela a été rappelé au tout
début de de cette soirée nous donne
aussi des respons ité des atouts et
peut-être une fierté de pouvoir parler
de de ces sujets j'assume de dire que
nous avons toujours été et nous sommes
plutôt de bonses élèves en la matière
c'est au choix visionnaire du général de
Gaul de Georges Pompidou que nous devons
d'ailleurs ce résultat dans les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre nous
sommes sans doute un des pays les plus
vertueux au monde et si nous le sommes
c'est c'est parce que d'autres venant de
notre famille politique de celle dont
nous sommes les héritiers ont effectué
les choix les plus
pertinents nous le disons clairement
nous connaissons les causes de ce
dérèglement
climatique nous en connaissons les
causes grâce au consensus scientifique
en consensus c'est peut-être un grand
mot mais grâce à la vérité scientifique
elle a été ce soir exprimée qui en
constate partout les effets nous le
mesurons autour de nous nous le
mesurons depuis l'Amazonie nous le
mesurons à travers les grands incendies
qui cet été encore on menacé des lieux
et des territoires entiers nous le
mesurons grâce ou à cause plutôt de la
récurrence et de la gravité de plus en
plus forte des épisodes climatique
exceptionnelle et je suis unu d'un élu
d'un territoire dans les alpes maritimes
qui a connu sans doute un des événements
climatiques les plus douloureux les plus
tragiques il y a 3 ans quasiment jour
pour jour avec le déferlement dans les
montagnes du opénissois de la tempête
Alex alors dans ce contexte
naturellement nous devons agir et ce
soir nous sommes là je le redis avec
humilité mais pour tracer les
perspectives et pour
repositionner notre famille politique au
cœur de ces enjeux
d'enjeux économique scientifique
climatique politique aussi sociaux parce
que derrière il y a la vie d'hommes et
de femmes qui dépendent directement des
choix que nous serons amenés à faire et
que nous devons faire aujourd'hui nous
devons
agir certes je le redis la France n'est
pas resté passive la droite n'est pas
restée passive notre héritage parle pour
nous et il nous a été
rappelé ne laissons pas et c'est
peut-être un préambule à mon propos la
France être accusée
d'inaction depuis
1990 nous avons diminué nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre nos émissions de
CO2 de 20 % 150 millions de tonnes de
CO2
mais soyons également lucide sur la
portée de nos
actions si nous avons économisé 100
millions de tonnes d'émission annuelles
depuis
1990 la Chine a augmenté les siennes de
11 milliards dans la même période le
défi climatique mes amis est un défi
mondial la France seule ne sauvera pas
le monde ce constat relève de l'évidence
mais il nous invite pour
autant à être les moteurs de l'action et
naturellement il doit nous conduire à
dépasser ces discours qui dans une forme
de résignation ou
d'impuissance nous soulligne que tout
seul nous ne pourrons rien faire certes
mais ce n'est pas une raison justement
pour rester impuissant et immobile il
nous invite et ces défis nous invitent à
construire nos politiques écologiques
avec réalisme et
efficacité tout en évitant plusieurs
écueils d'abord l'écueil de l'écologie
punitive cela a été dit et je salue les
intervenants qui avant moi l'ont
souligné notamment Bruno rotaillot je
salue par la même Olivier marlex le
président du groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale Antoine l'a l'a rappelé
aussi cette écologie punitive c'est une
écologie qui nuit à la cause qu'elle
prétend défendre c'est une écologie que
les Français n'acceptent pas et qu'ils
n'accepteront pas car elle se fait
contre eux et surtout sans eux dicté
souvent par des approches totalement
déconnectées technocratiques de la
réalité cette
approche si nous ne la modifions pas
elle chassera bientôt les plus modestes
les plus pauvres les plus précaires des
centr-villees
elle les privera de capacité à se
déplacer et elle introduira de nouvelles
formes de ségrégation et donc elle
rendra impossibles les objectifs qu'elle
prétend
atteindre c'est l'écologie des acronymes
ZFE DP zan une écologie qui aujourd'hui
risque de manquer totalement son but en
rendant une cause essentielle
particulièrement
impopulaire l'autre écueil qu'il
convient
d'éviter c'est l'écologie de la com qui
mise sur le gigantisme des dépenses pour
donner l'illusion de l'action avec des
coûts écrasants mais des bénéfices
environnementaux bien faible cette
écologie de la communication à outrance
et de surquoi part particulièrement
perméable aux
idéologies impuissante face au plus
grand écueil que nous devons combattre
le totalitarisme vert c'est la tyrannie
d'une ologie qui aspire à régenter
chaque coin de la
société et ne
tolère aucune dissidence qui veut
planifier jusqu'au détail de nos vies et
pour qui la liberté individuelle
constitue un
obstacle ne soit soyons pas naïf pour
ces vrais rouges Repin en vert la crise
climatique n'est que
l'opportunité de recaser de vieilles lub
et de prendre la revanche sur
d'importantes défaites nous avons nous
le devoir de porter une
alternative pour leur refuser le
monopole de cette écologie et tout
simplement ce soir c'est ce que nous
voulons porter défendre et c'est ce
pourquoi nous devons être
mobilisés en disant tout d'abord que
l'écologie n'a pas besoin d'idéodologue
elle a besoin d'abord de chercheurs et
de scientifiques et je salue ceux qui
ont été là ce soir pour cela il est
primordial
d'investir massivement dans la recherche
dans la science pour être à
l'avant-garde de tous les défis
techniques et de porter des plans
ambitieux qui rassemble réunissent fé
décideurs chercheurs ingénieurs
entrepreneurs oui bien sûr évidemment et
nous le redisons avec force nous
aspirons nous voulons et nous allons y
parvenir par notre méthode à la
neutralité
carbone pour cela oui nous devons nous
voulons décarboner
l'énergie mais pour cela nous devons
porter et renouer avec les grandes
ambitions qui ont été celles des pères
fondateurs pour cela il nous faut un
plan pour la production de batterie
électrique question de souveraineté
essentielle pour cela il nous faut un
plan pour l'hydrogène qui peut devenir
l'énergie de demain un plan pour les
productions pour la production d'énergie
alternative je pense en particulier aux
hydroliennes mais à bien d'autres
techniques qui aujourd'hui sont encore
expérimentales un plan pour les
carburants de synthèse pour le quéson
vert pour des moteurs non
polluants bref l'actualité
internationale nous rappelle une fois
encore combien il est important de
s'émanciper du pétrole pour que le
porte-monnaie des Français cesse de
subir les contrecoups du désordre
mondial c'est une question d'écologie
bien sûr c'est aussi une question de
pouvoir d'achat pour beaucoup nos
concitoyens enfin un vaste plan
nucléaire pour que nous redevenions
l'avant-garde que nous y étions hier
avant que ces graves erreurs que furent
la fermeture de Fessenheim
ou l'abandon du projet Astrid nous prive
de cette
place ce plan pour le
nucléaire doit s'appuyer sur un S
soutien infaillible à toutes les
innovations je pense en particulier au
projet de mini réacteur porté tant par
EDF que par nos start-up il nous faudra
sans doute plusieurs dizaines de PR pour
parvenir à la neutralité carbone en
2050 30 à 35 selon les spécialistes avec
un coût de plusieurs centaines de
milliards d'euros qu'il faudra financer
l'écologie dans ce contexte aura besoin
d'intelligence mes amis la France n'en
manque pas à nous de d'aiguillonner
cette intelligence de la fédérer de la
mobiliser dans la bonne direction alors
oui notre devoir c'est d'investir dans
la matière grise de retrouver
d'urgence nos
capacités pour consacrer des moy MIF à
la
recherche nous les retrouverons bien sûr
tout d'abord en rétablissement de
l'ordre dans nos finances nous y
travaillons cher an
jeunevard nous le retrouverons dans nos
finances mais aussi par un rééploiement
de l'État vers ses missions
stratégiques nous le retrouverons en
nous dotant d'un fond
souverain d'un outil puissant qui a déjà
qui ont déjà fait leur preuve dans
d'autres nations ou dans certains de nos
régions et je pense en particulier à
ouverneuronalp sous l'impulsion de
Laurent
vquier nous devons
flécher les milliers de milliards
d'épargne 5000 milliards aujourd'hui
d'euros
d'épargne que ça soit dans des dépôts
que ça soit dans des livrées d'assurance
vie que ce soit dans des placements
financiers 5000 milliards
d'euros qui peuvent être disponibles si
nous savons les orienter notamment grâce
à une fiscalité incitative
ou grâce à des intérêts qui peuvent
porter en eux une part de notre avenir
qui sont fléchés vers la mobilisation de
cette épargne pour participer à l'effort
commun en agissant ainsi nous
retrouverions des marges de manœuvre
sans alourdir le fardeau fiscal qui pèse
sur les Français le rapport
pisaniféie a posé un diagnostic il a
chiffré les investissements dans les
différents secteurs aujourd'hui 30 % des
émissions proviennent des transports 20
% de
l'agriculture 20 % du logement 20 % de
l'industrie 10 % de l'énergie 3 % des
déchets voilà ce sont des ordres de
grandeur
plusieurs centaines de milliards d'euros
ont été flichés pour aboutir à cette
neutralité carbone en 2050 et pour
abourtir à l'objectif de diminution de
55 % en 2030 c'est demain 7 ans à peine
ça veut dire que depuis
90 on a accompris un tiers du trajet de
l'objectif que l'on va demain devoir
accomplir en 7 ans c'est un effort
considérable qui nécessitera des
investissements mais la pire des
réponses c'est celle qui a été apportée
par la conclusion du rapport
fisaniférie qui n'est que fiscale qui ne
que peut se traduire que par un
alourdissement des prélèvements
obligatoires que notre pays ne pourra
pas supporter que d'autres pourront
peut-être supporter mais que la France
ne peut pas se permettre de supporter
alors que nous sommes desjà
les champions du monde des prélèvements
obligatoires avec un taux record de 45,4
% de notre richesse nationale donc cette
réponse fiscale du tout fiscal au défi
environnemental constitue une lourde
erreur et même une faute afin de
financer cette transition écologique
indispensable nous devons
porter l'exigence d'une fiscalité verte
intelligente orienté davantage sur la
consommation que sur la
production avec cette taxe carbone à la
frontière de l'Europe selon le modèle
défendu par 28 prix Nobel et qui permet
de discriminer les productions décarboné
des productions
polluantes une taxe qui bénéficierait à
l'industrie verte française à l' rendant
compétitive face aux industries
polluantes chinoises ou américaines
une taxe qui éviterait aussi les trous
dans la raquette de notre actuel système
européen auquel échappe la moitié des
émissions une taxe associé à un
verdissement de la TVA afin de ne pas
seulement marquer à la hausse les biens
de consommation qui polluent mais en
marquant aussi à la baisse ceux qui sont
peu carbonés sur le modèle du nutriscore
inventons un écoscore qui pourrait
guider le consommateur en explicitant
l'impact environnemental de ses achats
cette fiscalité verte est une fiscalité
claire et incitative qui s'inscrit
facilement dans le quotidien de nos
compatriotes et par la même notre
écologie sera financée par la
croissance nous rejetons et je le
souligne aujourd'hui et on peut
naturellement apparaître des désaccords
avec a des interventions précédentes
mais c'est le cadre aussi de ces débats
de ces moments de ces rencontres nous
rejetons et je rejette absolument le
dangereux Dom de la décroissance par
l'investissement massif dans la science
par une fiscalité
intelligente nous pouvons et nous devons
porter une réindustrialisation verte qui
dynamise l'économie et dont les
bénéfices viendrait financer nos
politiques des politiques que nous
devons fonder sur l'ambition de protéger
la nature autant que les Français
protéger les Français des effets du
réchauffement climatique enortant ça a
été souligné façon très importante en
portant un modèle d'adaptation et c'est
peut-être notre différence c'est
peut-être aussi un des messages les plus
puissants que nous devons
installer des dégâts ont été commis une
évolution malheureusement
sur le
réchauffement celle que nous avons déjà
constaté ce degré qui a déjà été gagné
ou perdu plutôt depuis le début du
siècle
dernier nous ne le rattrapererons pas
notre devoir c'est tout à la fois de
nous adapter à l'évolution que hélas
nous devons constater et d'éviter
qu'elle ne s'aggrave dangereusement
c'est là le double défi mais cette
adaptation elle doit aussi nous guider
et guider nos sociétés
protéger l'accès au
logement protéger la mobilité des
Français protéger leur alimentation
protéger leur santé protéger leur
paysage tels sont aussi des défis qui
devont n guider dans cette approche
d'adaptation soyons mes amis des
écologistes de terrain et non des
écologistes de plateau ou de salon
faisons davantage confiance aux élus
qu'au bureaucrat
ou à ceux qui regardent cette question
simplement par le
prisme d'une sorte de communication
effrainée ces combats s'attaquent aux
effets du réchauffement
climatique nous pouvons pour cela oui je
le crois
ement encore agir et le faire avec
succès et efficacité c'est aussi cela ce
soir que je voulais exprimer un message
d'espérance beaucoup des regards portés
sur ces défis
Climaque sont guidé par une forme de
résiliation pessimiste ayons la volonté
de cet
optimisme ayons la volonté de l'action
qui va ch
l'inéluctable ce qui pourrait apparaître
comme
uneéluctable issue tragique ou
dramatique nous devons porter une
espérance c'est notre responsabilité de
ne pas nous
résigner certes de nous adapter mais de
porter ce moteur puissant d'une nouvelle
espérance nous devons aussi être les
acteurs d'une prise de conscience
internationale nous ne le ferons pas
tout seul naturellement mais alors que
la réunion des 197 pays a démonté toutes
ces limites prenons plutôt l'initiative
d'un G7 climat avec les SEP principaux
pollueurs la Chine les États-Unis l'Inde
la Russie le Brésil l'Indonésie le Japon
et naturellement l'Union européenne
ensemble les membres de ce qui pourrait
constituer ce G7 climat représente les 2
tiers des émissions de gaz effet de
serre agir ensemble peut avoir un impact
déterminant et
essentiel dans le concert international
la France ne manque pas
d'atout et n'oublions jamais le premier
d'entre eux
l'Europe grâce à l'Europe nous pouvons
parler d'égal à égal avec les grands
pollueurs et je veux ici saluer
l'engagement de nos députés européens
notamment autour de François Xavier bami
qui ont été en première Lig pour
défendre ce mécanisme de contrôle aux
frontières de l'Europe qui vient
d'entrer en vigueur début septembre vous
l'aurez compris pour conclure mes amis
notre famille politique la droite
républicaine n'est pas en retrait des
questions
écologiques nous nous portons un modèle
cohérent et
alternatif notre modèle est celui de
l'effic
ité nous adapter d'ors et déjà aux
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
que nous vivons afin de construire des
sociétés durables et
respirables malgré les combats qui ont
déjà été perdus nous adapter aux grands
équilibres
internationaux afin de porter des
politiques à l'échelle de la planète qui
dépassent les effets d'annonce et qui
puisse remporter les combats de
demain des combats que nous n'avons plus
la possibilité le loisir ou la faculté
de perdre il en va d'une question de
survie notre modèle c'est l'adaptation
locale et nationale aux effets du
dérèglement climatique c'est une lutte
diplomatique et internationale déterminé
contre ces causes notre modèle c'est la
coprospérité de l'homme et de la
nature notre modèle c'est une écologie
du réel et du possible une écologie de
espérance une écologie de confiance dans
la science et dans l'avenir une écologie
de liberté et de croissance qui ne
renonce ni à la planète ni à la France
une écologie forte et efficace une
écologie
française